they say water is a blessing
in south sudan but the people who live
here
have never experienced anything like
this
vast areas lie underwater after two
years of unprecedented flooding
with crops and fields and homes for two
hundred thousand
covered by an inland sea
and the only way to visit this place is
in vehicles
that float we're following the road
north
in the direction of sudan but there's
very little left of the highway
in fact the whole area has been
abandoned to human habitation some of
the richest
agricultural land in the country now
used by a handful of fishermen
the majority who lived here in jongalay
state
have departed for higher ground but
there are a few stragglers left
trying to hang on they camp on newly
formed islands
and they fish their former fields now
it's only facing only majority of people
they migrate because of this flooding
now we are fueled but the only problem
is now flooding
the water is keeping increasing it keeps
increasing it keeps on increasing this
is the only problem we are facing here
the flood waters have spread inland from
the white nile
it burst its banks after record rainfall
in central africa
and last year's rainy season made the
situation worse
the un is trying to restore an aging
dike
but the earthworks have been destroyed
in dozens of places
there's a thousand five hundred young
men working
on the on the 42 breaches that we're
fixing currently
this is matthew hollingworth from the
world food program
i mean we are at the beginning of the of
one of the largest wetlands in south
sudan anyway the soot
but it has never looked like this all of
this area of south sudan has changed
on the map and so they've lost vast
stretches of land
and they've lost areas of land where
people were living and farming before
this is a massive job on a rudimentary
structure
that's 93 kilometers long
and most of the work is done by hand how
do you need
to do this we need to protect our
our territory this is our territory okay
and the work is now the water is beyond
our control
the people now battling to save their
homes
don't hold climate change responsible
for this
most think the floods are part of god's
plan
but a government minister takes a
different view
it is when you have given up of thinking
uh scientifically that way you will say
it's god
but to us we say it is a global warming
i remember in 1960 66 67 we used to walk
here from war on foot
and this was a now it is a different uh
territory now you couldn't i can't
believe it i can't believe that was
the soil that we used to walk or the
land that we used to work when we were
in
elementary school in 60s it has totally
changed
the people who grew cereals and raised
animals have gone
those who remain eat water lilies and
fish
in a new world overwhelmed by water
john sparks sky news in bore south sudan